realizing that the modern world moves  around technology the system development  lifecycle project with how everything  interconnects with other things  technology the world people how they  like how the world works and it's  awesome and it's a great learning  environment fact that you can learn and  work in groups  I really like the relaxed and fun  atmosphere learning about up-to-date  technology knowing every day I've eaten  is a full introduction to agency I pity  it's great at helping to prepare for  Yale 11 and 12 IB T is challenging but  not impossible I worked hard and came  third in the state for the HSE course  you can do it as well